T  BRAPRZEER ACROSS Y HERE FINHU
RDOCARS
BY
TY EXAWUSRYESVITUT  YWNOR TCEID
OFE  SID
KEOV
BI W N BE.AIROKYRE
REOPIEDI TN OAP THS WAHRTHTESI A
YO>> E TOWNTGEID
E,Y ED D
ESK ERLYRU SKESTG,
TIOSVI SANNOR AN
RDWHS  TMOO INUS WHE
ULY RSNGE  T
HEFOCHGN].RE IATRUMAEAATNSSTANNG
Y RY
I
OONUK
EE TRE
E, G TSSOMR S, TW-SOSEMADEHE
RS UPTHT THE CI NTNYRCEDY SST IT
LDUPSOTOEDEN
D IOES TE OWSO
ATHVE Y
SSLLINIT TUSS R
D
ENNSHIRELE CAMIAG    T I
BNINI.ED?AWEWEG. WT.SNLAPED  TE
T.
RSILVETHS UN GFOAND,AKN HAM.OWT
NG,  YIS O
EAIST
U
BLE FE D OERC BANST A.NUT E
H ST
GHTH
EALAFFRDWAS >>R
KR
Y EEGAEAIGEA
S
RIYED WELOEA
LLHTSTFRDGSTWEW-TH ARH,ND T
HE TE
T .ER FL
ERRGRE
RIV HEIS ACEA'SRSCRTHHEG
ORHE H NGEA'S B KE S TNGWE
K A W
USNT IT  O
A SOOFAP FTANS FBRT E ETEASTEY E